[Music]
thank you
what are some of the most offensive
words in the English language mate
fieldwork gory these are some of the
latest to go in the banned list by
groups who deem them harmful how much
further can they go I'm joined Now by
columnist Lionel Shriver who wrote about
this in the magazine this week
thank you for coming on spectator TV
this week in your column you talk about
the words we're not supposed to say and
we're going to roll through a couple but
let's begin how you begin in your piece
housekeeping what's the problem
it doesn't qualify as any of the IST
words you know racist sexist ages Etc
um
but according to this University
Department in Washington it feels
gendered
and gender is in a way which is unfat a
woman that's right because
I suppose it's something that women used
to do so there are a lot of there are a
lot of other things we might start
eliminating
childbirth I've got a list
um if we stop Banning housekeeping how
does that actually manifest itself at
this University and the other words that
we're supposed to be using or that one
didn't come with a substitute but um
there are often in these Banning
documents that are now being issued
um in great quantity and unsurprisingly
coming out of the universities primarily
um
and they often tell you what you're
supposed to say instead
and unfailingly the substitutes are
awkward
um I'm really bad English sometimes even
ungrammatical uh a wordy and um and
don't mean the same thing at all and
actually Point here a lot of this is
coming from universities
um
is it because people are complaining or
ultimately these are academics looking
ahead and saying this these words should
not be used well
at a glance it seems as if these people
need to get a life right
um
but this is this this obsession with
language and and therefore uh
imposing virtue by Fiat
from above uh by means of controlling
the words that people are allowed to use
this has been
an obsession of the left for decades now
and we've all been through the what I
call the euphemism churn of constantly
being told that whatever you said last
week and however you called a certain
group last week you can't do it this
week and we used to talk about the
disabled all the time and that was
supposed to be the polite term because
we were told we couldn't say handicapped
anymore
um and now you can't even say disabled
because all of these words that mean a
person
have been demonized because that's
reducing a a human being to a single
trait so now you have to say
um people living with disabilities this
you see what I mean I mean the
clumsiness and the wordiness is typical
this doesn't seem to bother these people
um because they're terrible writers and
uh I theorize in the column that maybe
this is part of the scheme to just make
sure that they don't have any
competition where we're all terrible
writers now
yeah and you mentioned the word disabled
but reading your column I discovered
apparently American is also something
which could be offensive that's correct
we're not supposed to talk about
Americans anymore the problem is that uh
both the both the North and South
continents
of America include many many different
countries and Americans have co-opted
the term too
to relate only to them and that's not
fair so they shouldn't be able to use
that word anymore
so I suppose the term offenses were
getting quite broader use these days
um what do you think offense do you
think there is such a thing as an
offensive word like how should we Define
what events the word is I presume that
you're not going to put America in that
bracket
um I find the expression birthing people
offensive
okay so I am capable of being offended
and I won't use it as a matter of fact I
find almost all of this leftist jargon
offensive it offends me that isn't
imposed on me it's ugliness offense
offends me
um it's
a Relentless and remorseless repetition
offends me bad writing offends me and
lack of thinking offends me because
behind a lot of these terms it's using
language as a substitute for thinking
for yourself I'll be seeing much sign of
it sleeping I suppose into the
mainstream yet because I'm reading your
column I found it fascinating that some
of these words that I'm just using
briefly and we'll get to one which is I
think is
part of my podcast name wasn't the balls
he said ballsy and it is it's one that
is not supposed to be used
um but is there a sense that this is
still mainly in academic circles or
obviously you can see through
the trouble with this stuff is it does
tend to spread with plenty of evidence
of that there is almost an there was
almost a particular day in a particular
year when suddenly we stopped talking
about minorities I say we Loosely is I'm
I I'm moving mostly to the media you
couldn't say minorities anymore you had
to say people of color
and it was just is it it was as if
someone had passed a law it was so
Universal and it was so instantaneous
but I find the expression stilted it's
it's an Arcane construction it's absurd
and what makes it especially absurd is
that if you say colored people
you'll lose your job in fact people have
lost their job for saying colored people
I mean by accident but what's the
difference
I suppose if a group uh which is a group
that it's referring to is really
offended by that do you think that is
reason enough that people should you
know perhaps this is a matter of basic
courtesy start using other terms or is
that that them and it becomes a bit of a
slippery slope yeah
you anticipated my answer up to a point
yes and uh
although I seem to offend people all the
time I don't generally do it on purpose
uh so
up to a point I will comply
and use whatever term is acceptable and
seems respectful and
um but there's there's kind of a limit
because
especially in relation to the dis
disabled there's there have been so many
different words we're supposed to use
and you're not going to push me to use
an expression to the point of clumsiness
and
that would Mar the quality of my prose I
am not going to talk about people living
with disabilities or people living with
obesity
um
that's that's ridiculous and
accomplishes nothing right I don't see
why that's more respectful
it's just
bad English
so what is the best way to fight back
because and then my final question was a
the flight back but uh B
um you mentioned birthing but there any
words that you're going to ban for your
use and response
I don't think the answer is to fight
back by Banning after all that's the
problem I reject outright the idea that
people have the right to tell me which
words in the English language I may and
may not use
um so the first way you fight back is By
ignoring it right so
go ahead and use whatever words
pop into your head if they express what
you wanted to say then use them
and the other way to fight back is by
making fun of them and I find that with
uh the progressive left that's the one
thing they can't take
um they don't mind it if you call them
names and get angry
um and and seem mean and they don't even
mind it when you fight back with the
same kind of tactics that they use like
oh we're going to ban all this language
but they hate to be laughed at
and now on a slightly different topic
while we have you here I think a few
months ago when I was presenting
spectator TV you came on and he talked
about another of your columns which is
about Heating and I think it's one of
our most viewed clips of all time on
spectator TV
um so people can guess what the
Zeitgeist is but but we found it for
them and it's pretty cold at the moment
are you still sticking to your not
putting the heating on policy and that's
absolute emergency yes
um when I left uh our house was 10
degrees
and um
and
this is long underwear I won't show you
but I'm wearing
um long underwear underneath uh I walk
around in a coat
um
I get used to it but I type in gloves
and it's a little absurd
but
uh I think I pointed out in our
discussion on this topic last time is
that I view turning on the heat as
defeat
yeah and your bills are looking good
well they're twice as much as they were
a year ago but everyone's is
still small to figure as a result
um thank you Lionel for paying on
spectator TV always a pleasure
[Music]
thank you